rumors of Supreme Court Justice Anthony
Kennedy spittle retirement reignited
Friday when Nevada Republican senator
Dean Heller addressed a closed-door
meeting in Las Vegas longtime court
Watchers dismissed Heller's comments
noting he does not serve on the Senate
Judiciary Committee and does not
personally know the media shy Kennedy
in addition Kennedy has already hired
his clerks for the courts next session
and the High Court is one of the few
places in Washington where secrets
really are kept it's something that's
really drilled into the new clerks as
they start that confidentiality is of
utmost importance as they always say
those who talk don't know and those who
know don't talk so at this point it's
really just all speculation Heller may
have ulterior motives in feeding the
Kennedy retirement rumor he said he
hopes a vacancy would inspire voters
he's in a tight primary race against
perennial Nevada Republican candidate
Danny Tarkanian it's a great issue for
the conservative base they're very fired
up by the thought of getting another
Supreme Court justice perhaps like
justice Neil Dorsett if there is a
Supreme Court retirement it may not
necessarily be the 81 year old Kennedy
Justice Stephen Breyer is 79 and Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg turns 85 on Friday
it's very easy to imagine this president
having multiple nominees to the Supreme
Court and that's of course one of the
most long lasting impacts any president
has as speculation builds about the
Supreme Court the Trump administration
is moving quickly to fill 17 lifetime
vacancies on US courts of Appeal and
another 121 district court vacancies it
is in those course where 99 percent of
the nation's federal court decisions are
made